قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه رغم الثمن الباهظ الذي تتكبده
اسرائيل خلال الحرب الدائره في غزه فانها
ستواصل القتال حتى النهايه وجدد نتنياهو
في مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه قوله
ان اسرائيل لن توقف الحرب قبل تحقيق
اهدافها ندفع ثمنا باهظا جدا في الحرب لكن
لا مفر امامنا الا ان نواصل القتال قواتنا
قضت حتى الان على في المخربين نواصل بكل
قوتنا حتى النهايه والنصر لنستكمل تحقيق
كل اهدافنا بالقضاء على حماس واعاده
مختطفين وضمان ان تشكل غزه اي تهديد لدوله
اسرائيل ينضم الينا الان من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم اهلا بك معنا في سياق
متابعه هذه التصريحات المتكرره لبنيامين
نتنياهو الذي يتحدث عن مواصله الحرب لكنه
في ذات الوقت لا يعطي تفسيرا لعدم قدرتهم
على استعاده ما يسميهم بالرهاب ويمضي في
الحرب دون خطه واضحه لاستعاده
هؤلاء نعم عبد السلام هو ما يغضب
المتظاهرين من اهالي المخطوفين عفوا
الاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واولئك الداعمين لهم نتنياهو
في خطاباته السياسيه عند ما يتحدث عن هذه
الحرب ويرضي جمهور اليمين الذي يطالب بان
تكون هذه الحرب حتى اكثر وحشيه ويعتبر ان
الحرب الدائره حاليا هي حرب لانقاذ دوله
اسرائيل وان تضحيات مهما كانت سواء من
جنود او من اسرى فهي تضحيات مقبوله لذلك
نسمع من نتنياهو هذا الخطاب وفيه رسائل
متعدده حول استمراره في هذه العمليه
العسكريه حتى ما يقول بانه النصر وان كان
كان الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى اللحظه لم يتمكن
من تحقيق هذه الاهداف اي اهداف القضاء على
حركه حماس التي لا تزال تقاتل من مسافات
صفريه في قطاع غزه ولا تزال قبل ايام
قليله قادره على اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
البلدات الاسرائيليه فهذا الخطاب لرئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو فهم ايضا عبد
السلام هنا في الشارع الاسرائيلي بانه رد
تلميح على المبادره المصريه التي تحدثت عن
ثلاث مراحل تنهي هذه الحرب اولا بوقف
اطلاق النار ومن ثم الوصول الى تسويه
سياسيه تنتهي بهذا بها هذه الحرب البعض
هنا في اسرائيل فهم هذا الخطاب على انه
رساله او رد بالتلميح على هذه المبادره
المصريه وان كان مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
سيدرس هذه المبادره يوم غد الاثنين في
اجتماعات اجتماع له لكن هذا الخطاب
السياسي لبنيامين نتنياهو
سواء سواء اليوم ما قاله اليوم او ما بثه
من
تسجيلات في الايام السابقه كلها تحمل لغه
التحدي لا يبدو ان لديه خيارات اخرى او
استراتيجيات اخرى يعرضها ضمن هذه
الخطابات بعد ان حتى ان بعد ان تسرب عن عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان لديه خطه للدخول الى
المرحله الثالثه جددت جدد الرقيب العسكري
عبر بيانه حظر اي منشور عن تلك العمليات
العسكريه وغيرها من الملفات الا بعد
العوده اليه في
محاوله لكبح والسيطره على روايه المعركه
من الناحيه الاسرائيليه بان تكون روايه
واحده وهي الروايه الرسميه وهي روايه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو عبد السلام شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات احمد هز
مراسل الجزيره كان معنا من
تلابيب